Deutschland and English.
We refer to this nation as Germany,
a name given to the region by the Romans who called the lens east of the Rhine,
get ammonia Germania.
The history of Germany is not necessarily the history of a single nation,
but of a people administering German nations.
A situation which is not only one of the ancient past,
but even one which the German people have faced in our modern age.
This nation's history is fascinating,
impressive,
and profound.
However,
much of it is overshadowed by more recent events.
While the events of the first and especially the second world wars with Germany
at the center of both are of major historical importance,
we must also discuss the hundreds,
in fact,
thousands of years of German history prior to these events to understand what
Germany is in the big picture of things.
In this documentary,
we're going to do just that today here on fire of learning.
We're going to explore the history of Germany from its earliest beginnings to
the modern age.
The land we know is Germany was first inhabited by modern humans around 35,000
years ago.
The germanic peoples.
However,
our rides in the area near the 3000 years ago as climate change prompted
migration from their origin southward from modern Scandinavia and northern
Germany,
it is around this time that the Germanic languages and cultures began to become
distinct from the people farther north as they moved.
They encountered and bordered other people's such as the Celts,
Slavs,
Baltic peoples,
and Scythians.
Much of what we know of these early people and their lives prior to Roman
contact comes to us from archaeology linguistic analysis and even genetic
testing.
Written records of the peoples of northern Europe in ancient times are scarce,
is the earliest few written accounts are fragments left from the fascinating yet
mysterious men known as pathologists have Musalia,
a Greek explorer and the third century BC.
More detailed descriptions come to us from the Romans who ever expanding
inevitably came into more direct contact,
very direct contact.
One of the first main interactions between the Germanic tribes and the Romans
was the Cambrian war of one 13 to one o one BC sparked as tribes from modern
Germany known as the Kimbery to Tony's and I'm bronies moved further south as
their land farther north had become less hospitable.
They would be defeated,
but this would only mark the beginning of a long intense relationship between
Rome and the German tribes.
The first three or first the Germans as they get a money was Julius Caesar.
Though this classification was more about geography than an actual analysis of
the peoples living in the region.
Who are those shared?
A number of similarities were rather diverse linguistically and culturally and
far from unified.
They in fact were often at war with each other.
Those in Gaul,
we're the Kells.
Those across the Rhine River where the Germans,
he them largely as barbarians.
They were a people who lacked towns and cities and too dependent on primitive
subsistence agriculture,
often leading very difficult lives in comparison to the Romans.
They followed a form of paganism which was similar to others in western Europe
at the time.
Specifically to Norse mythology with an emphasis on nature and the natural
forces around them.
They worshiped gods such as money to Woden sooner and Frig.
You are likely more familiar with these gods by the days named after them.
Mona dog two's,
dog wardens,
dog owners,
dog free dog.
They literally put the England after the fall of Rome via the Anglo Saxons
Tacitus later add it to the Roman understanding,
describing the Germans as a large people with reddish hair and piercing blue
eyes,
referring to the 50 or so dramatic tribes inhabiting the region.
At the time.
At times,
relations between the Romans and the Germans were peaceful and cooperative
trade,
intermarriage and other interactions to place.
At other times there was a brutal warfare under Augustus Caesar.
The Romans would actually attempt to expand into gear Manea.
The area,
however,
was a much harder region to enter and subdue with.
In Gaul,
the thick forested and marshy landscape.
We're very foreign to the Italian Romans and heighten their fears of the
barbarian savages they thought were living within them.
The lack of roads and major towns made the logistics and nightmare for large
Roman army.
As they moved eastward,
the Romans would begin encroaching on the Germans.
Further,
they would build settlements such as Colonia and oak.
Why granny,
which would become cities like loan and Orkin or in a Chappelle.
The Romans attempted to quickly subdue the Armani,
placing taxes on them,
confiscating their weapons,
replacing their old legal systems,
and essentially taking some of them,
particularly the sounds of Nudelman as hostages.
These boys are raised in Rome as Romans,
largely with the hopes that they would return to gear Manea loyal to and
cooperative with Rome.
In the end,
though,
this process would come to backfire on the Romans.
One of these romanized Germans was a man named Arminius,
known in German as Hermando.
Arminius was taken and put into the Roman army,
being the son of a true skin chief during a campaign into his homeland under
quintillion as far as he would later defect to his native side and use his
knowledge of the Roman army to ambush and the feed them.
And September of nine and the Roman army was ambushed by Arminius and an army of
United German tribes near Cal Coryza.
And one is remembered as a battle of two to Berg forest.
Around 20,000 Romans were brutally decimated by the dramatic troops in one of
the most significant battles in Roman history,
if not the most significant for the Germans.
This was a great victory.
Arminius was hailed as a great warrior and in the eyes of some is Germany's
first hero for the Romans.
This was a horrible disaster.
They withdrew their designs of the province of magnet girl Manea,
preventing not only the Romanization of Germany,
but even beyond Arminius would continue to lead,
perhaps envisioning himself as a future king of all the Armani,
but he was murdered by a political rivals before us.
Such a thing as a United German nation could come to fruition and Kermani are
returned to the Dis United State.
It was in prior to these events,
the main cause of this,
the concept of gear Manea was a Roman invention existing in the minds of Romans,
but not in the hearts of the many different peoples living in the region,
at least not yet.
This would not be the end of the story of Romano driven relations far from it.
In fact,
in the second and third century and as room started showing signs of the k,
the Germanic tribes began coalescing and expanding these tribes would have a
significant impact not only on Germany and in fact not only on Europe,
but the entire Roman empire,
the goths,
vandals,
Franks of the money,
macro money,
but very angles,
Saxons,
lombards and so forth.
The goths would be the most troublesome to the Romans of these groups,
rating,
pillaging and destabilizing many parts of the empire in the fourth century.
As the huns began moving westward,
pressure was placed on the dramatic peoples and they too are forced to move
westward.
As the hunt spilled into the borders of modern Germany,
the Romans significantly weakened at this point,
lack the power to stop the massive waves of people crossing their borders and
settling in our territories and instead attempted to integrate them.
Much of the army,
in fact would later come to be comprised in a majority by dramatic soldiers.
The intention was for these foreigners to be romanized in many ways.
They were in the fourth century,
the ones in Rome who were Christianized and were introduced to the advances of
Roman society around three 50 and the Bible was translated into the gothic
language.
Not exactly German.
There was no German yet,
but it is an ancient relative of German and even English,
which perhaps you can see in this comparison of texts,
the dramatic peoples who left behind their homeland.
We're adapting,
but they would not fully assimilate into the Roman empire.
Rather they would replace it as the Roman Empire fell.
Many of its successor states were formed by or were taken over by rulers from
the Germanic tribes.
These kingdoms would arise in many places even as far as North Africa.
Some of these kingdoms would disappear.
The majority would not become German eyes,
but rather the German ruler's assimilated into the native population.
But some such as the Anglo Saxon dominance and modern England would be more
permanent.
Having a lasting effect on the language and ethnic identity of the people on the
island.
Though never truly under Roman rule and outside the main conflicts caused by
their kin care Manea itself was still directly impacted by the fall of the Roman
empire.
In the coming centuries.
It would be thrown into conflict with Rome successors.
Dates from these conflicts,
however,
would rise further uniformity and cohesion among the Germans
though consider the dark age for many reasons.
The early medieval ages where a time in which we may find the roots of modern
Europe along with its cultures,
languages and ethnic identities.
Germany is no exception to this.
While the east of the modern nation was at this time and habited by Slavs and
the West and south Frank's Friesian,
Bavarians Saxons,
alimony and Thorin gins were slowly becoming more recognizably Germans.
The Franks are of considerable importance.
They would unify the tribe and extend beyond modern Germany.
Power was beginning to center,
run the Franks in a former gall unrich Clovis to first the mayor of engine
dentisty who became king of the Franks.
In a four 81 Clovis began to expand his domain with forests and lands held by
the last bastions of Romans and other dramatic tribes.
By five Oh eight his empire extended throughout a large share of modern Germany,
France,
and the low countries.
It wasn't this year that he made the decision to convert his kingdom to
Catholicism beginning large scale conversion of the people's formerly outside
the Christian Roman Empire when Clovis died around five 12 and his kingdom was a
vital among his four sons and accordance with Frankish tradition.
This process of the vision of Lens among the sons of the Frankish rulers would
impede the unified growth of their domain and the emergence of something like a
true nation state or even a true kingdom in a more modern sense for quite some
time and in fact,
much of the situation of early medieval Germany is defined by this practice
which is called portable inheritance as opposed to primogeniture where the first
born child gets about everything.
Sometimes these rulers would work cohesively as they were expected to.
The intention was after all to create separate domains of one larger kingdom,
but other times saw crippling civil wars.
The Franks would continue pushing into Germany,
but in fighting would continue in a kingdom would eventually be divided into
three regions.
Noise Tria Australia and Burgundy with modern Germany belonging mostly to
Australia,
along with conflict between themselves.
There were also constantly involved in wars with foreigners including the
westward expanding,
Slavs and AVRs depending on the circumstances and the Frankish domains.
At the time the Germans would rural with more or less autonomy.
Paganism was still common in Germany itself,
especially among the majority of the country outside Frankish rural,
and there was yet to be written German language apart from the aforementioned
Gothic,
which was being forgotten in favor of Latin.
In six 13 [inaudible] second of moisture reunited the Franks and established
what is called the mayor of the pallets to help with the administration of the
kingdom.
In effect,
a kind of prime minister,
Germany would continue throughout this period.
At the center of a age,
the German peoples were caught in a power struggle between many competing forces
on the continent,
but we're still United somewhat by a common culture and similar languages.
By the eighth century,
the Merovingians had become effectively puppet kings.
The men with the real power were the mayors of the palace and seven 18 Charles
Martel secure this position.
Charles the hammer,
as his name meant an old French is remembered most famously for his victory at
the battle of tour where he defeated the Muslim who my odds preventing nations
such as France or even Germany from Islamic takeover.
However,
Charles would struggle not only with Muslims but Germans as well.
Before that battle,
which took place in seven 32 he was involved in the war against Varian's Saxons,
Lamonti and Free Asians from seven 18 to seven 30 VBA Varian's.
We're often independent minded and uncooperative,
not something that would change anytime soon,
and the Saxons were pagans who frequently rated Frankish territory in seven 51
the veil was officially taken off by Martella successor with the support of the
Pope Charles Martel son Pepin the short depose.
The last Merovingian kings show the Rick the third with the end of the mirror
visions came a new dynasty.
The Carol Engines Pepin would rule for 10 years.
His most major contribution,
which would have a permanent effect on Europe was the donation of Pepin,
which was essentially a land grant to the pope,
which would be known as the papal states.
However,
it would be his son who laid the foundations for much of modern Europe,
including the German nation state,
and he's remembered for no less than this achievement,
often called patera.
I I by the father of Europe,
he's referred to as Charles the Great Carl there.
Grossa or Charlemagne Charles United,
both halves of the Frankish empire and 70 71 when his brother Carlo and died of
natural causes almost immediately.
He set his sights on expanding into Germany where he would come into contact
with one of his greatest foes.
The restless Pagan Saxons led by rulers such as one called Vito [inaudible],
which meant forest child back then that implies something fierce,
more like a wolf as opposed to you know,
freedom flowerchild and seven 72 Charlemagne invaded Saxony subjugating one of
the May tribes and desecrating Pagan religious monuments such as a hollow tree
known as Earman Sule,
which the Saxons believed held up the sky.
Charlemagne did not stay long.
Turning his attention to Italy specifically toward the troublesome Lombards,
his sentence of German invaders with a name meaning long beards who were
agitating the pope and Italy.
Nevertheless,
things weren't quite so finished in Saxony.
In fact,
war would continue for 30 years until eight Oh four the primary reason for this
was paganism,
but also be fractured structure of Saxon society.
There were not unified and the various groups acted independently and had to be
subdued when Charlemagne was distracted by other conflicts,
especially a tended to revolt attacking Frankish soldiers,
priests and churches.
The Franks would respond bitterly and one incident and Verdian and seven 82
Charlemagne order that 4,500 people and be beheaded for a rebellion even by his
contemporaries.
This act was seen as excessive brutality as he subdued the Saxons,
he and his missionaries and Forest Christianity on them harshly.
The penalty for refusing baptism was death and seven 85 Vito kin surrendered and
willingly agreed to be baptized.
The other Saxons fought on.
Charlemagne continued to expand eastward into other parts of Germany as well and
even beyond.
In seven 88 he went to war with the Bavarians.
He would then expand further eastward from there fighting the AVRs and Slavs
after years of conquest and conversions on Christmas day in 800 Aidy,
Charlemagne was crowned emperor of the Romans by Pope Leo the third.
This was the beginning of something that would outlive him for a little over a
thousand years.
It was not just a pump as title.
As time went on,
some historians would consider Charlemagne to be the first holy Roman emperor
that has not agreed upon some consider out of the first whom we will talk about
soon to be the first true ruler a century later because Charlemagne was not
actually the ruler of the holy Roman Empire and the sense that it would later
take the term holy would not be added until a few hundred years later,
but the intention was for Charlemagne,
his empire to be viewed as the reincarnation of Rome.
Although admittedly he and his subjects tended to prefer their Frankish identity
as time goes on,
the holy Roman Empire would not really live up to any of its names as we shall
see the intention of Pope Leo.
The third was to be the spiritual leader of the Christian world and Charlemagne
the secular and for the emperor in Pope to work in tandem ruling over a new
Rome.
The intended and mutually beneficial relationship here,
however,
would eventually become a source of conflict.
This event also caused dispute with the Byzantines and not for the last time who
were fairly offended by the notion of Charlemagne calling himself emperor of
Rome when they consider themselves the Romans.
Remember of course,
that the Roman empire only fell in the west.
The east or the Byzantines had continued and we're still standing strong.
Pope Leo wasn't concerned by this.
The Byzantine head of state at the time was a woman,
so he felt that the title was vacant,
but tension between East and West would not quickly does appear.
In fact,
it would carry on until the death of Byzantium itself.
Following his coordination,
Charlemagne would continue to expand his domain.
In total,
his empire would encompass almost all of western and central Europe and even
beyond.
Charlemagne was not only a man of the sword.
However,
he oversaw a number of intellectual achievements that have led to his rain being
referred to as the Carolingian renaissance.
Charlemagne died and eight 14 eight d the empire he constructed form the basis
for rebirth of Europe.
He had intended to divide his kingdom up among his sons a practice so firmly
rooted in tradition that not even he would break it,
but only one Louie or Ludvig would outlive him.
While that may seem as though having one air would hold the empire together,
Louis the pious would not rule as strongly as his father had and would often
have to struggle to keep the empire together against an array of enemies
assembling from outside as empire and even against his own sons.
Louie was not a harsh ruler,
but he was quite simply not the right man for the times.
In fact,
he has said who have wanted to have been a priest rather than an emperor.
He died in eight 40 and after a series of external and internal wars,
he had tried to leave the empire to his eldest son to prevent the collapse of
Christian Europe,
but his other sons rebelled successfully against this decision.
Two years following the battle of font and NOI and eight 41 the kingdom was
divided into three with the treaty of fair doing Charles,
the bald would rule the western portion,
low tar.
The lands in the center and Ludvig the Lens and the east,
specifically the regions east of the Rhine and north of Italy,
Bavaria,
Franconia,
Saxony and Swabia.
This event is considered a very significant milestone in German history,
east and west.
Frankia now with different languages and cultures would be basically permanently
severed and we're on a path to develop and to separate nations.
France and Germany.
Ludvig would later receive the old Roman title gear,
Monica's,
which meant conqueror of the Germans.
Ludvig is promptly known as Louis,
the German or Ludvig there Deutscher and German or lewd fig.
The mites and check at this time as the German identity was in a very important
stage of coming together.
The peoples of Europe disagreed on what exactly to call this variety of people
with similar cultures and languages.
This issue was never really resolved and today there remains a variety of names
for Germany in different languages which are seemingly unrelated.
This treaty of their Dune.
While that provided stability would not end,
the conflict between the three brothers permanently and fighting would continue
on and off.
In fact,
after Charlemagne,
Germany's history for the next few centuries would be marked by constant
conflict.
Germany or east Frankia would be surrounded by rivals at various times fighting
Norse vikings,
the Slavs,
which would later include groups such as the Moravians and Polish.
The Magyars not want to loot Vic's doorstep.
The northern Italians,
the Saracens for Muslims,
the Byzantines and the West,
Franks or later the French,
the name,
the main ones,
arguably east Frankie.
His biggest enemy though was itself.
Divisions among family would constantly fracture and via the land threatening
its very existence.
For centuries it was not long before the Kingdom of Middle Frankia will be
broken apart.
It was the least stable of the three and had even less cohesion than that of
really France and early Germany,
which though facing division had at least similar languages and ethnic groups.
Many different ones were forming in an awkwardly,
formed a territory now encompassing the Netherlands down to Italy.
The territory of Lorraine.
However,
between modern France and Germany is a corruption of low towering.
Yeah.
And this region still carries a name of low tar,
which is more obvious in a modern German name not ringing Ludvig and Charles
eventually sees Lorraine and divided it in a treaty of misson.
This would not solve the dispute over the region,
though in fact,
it would be a constant cause of conflict for over a Millennium Ludvig.
The German died in [inaudible] 76 and as you probably expect at this point,
his kingdom was divided among his sons Ludvig,
the younger Carla [inaudible] and Carl,
who would sometime later be known as Carl,
their decay or an English Charles the fat who actually briefly reunited
Charlemagne's empire and became holy Roman emperor,
not so much because he was a great conqueror,
but because every other air in Germany and France had died,
Carl would be the last to rule over a United Frankish empire in the late sixties
the Magyars had finally reached East Frankia rating a territory mercilessly and
centering their power not far away in the modern nation of Hungary,
which the Magyars would later be responsible for.
Founding Mush of Carl's rain was spent dealing with them,
as well as the vikings whose raids by now reached the city of Ochin in which
Charlemagne had centered much of his empire and where his palace was built as
well as Paris and the Rhineland.
Things were not going well for Carl.
His rule was brief is lifelong struggle with sickness and epilepsy made ruling
over an uncooperative empire,
difficult,
and he was deposed by his nephew,
Arnulf and eight 87 Arnold would not be able to claim the entire kingdom.
However,
and the Frankish empire split apart this time permanently.
But Avaya,
it's between the two halves were too great to seal.
By now.
Arnold merely retain the German area of the country.
East Frankia importantly,
are enough.
Did not merely take the throne,
was elected by the nobility to became the concept of electing leaders in Germany
data back to ancient times,
and as we shall see,
did not disappear anytime soon are an officer.
Terrain would be marked by unsuccessful wars with the Slavs Vikings,
Moravians,
and Magyars.
He died in eight and 99 and was succeeded by his six year old son Ludovic the
child who would only live to the age of 20 throughout allude Vic's rain.
Every corner of journey was ravaged by the Maggie or horseman.
Furthermore,
the Dukes of the various regions,
Dutch,
he's obese,
Frankia asserted more independence,
threatening to break the kingdom apart.
Ludvig the child died in the year nine 11 as the last Carolingian kings,
but Germans had to focus on their own affairs and elected a king from outside
the Carolingian line rather than respect,
Charles is simple,
king of France,
his claim to the throne one such a fair was the Magyars who were a more major
threat to the Germans and the Vikings,
which France was focused on.
Conrad Duke of [inaudible] was elected to be their king.
The election of rulers was resurfacing as a common trend and that is here where
we begin to see the complex political structure of what would be called the holy
Roman Empire arise.
Although Conrad did not receive the title of Emperor of Rome that had gone to
rulers in Italy at this point,
becoming essentially a reward.
The pope gave out to any ruler who would help him.
Conrad though king a name,
did not have much authority over the Dukes who made him king and he would
struggle to assert his authority throughout his reign,
often fighting both his subjects and foreigners like he was more like a grand
Duke.
Then King.
This power struggle between the monarch and nobles of the semi autonomous states
that put them there would be another feature which would mark the holy Roman
empire,
his existence and the long run.
Conrad would actually be severely wounded fighting the rebellious variance and
on his deathbed he proposed to his brother that Heinrich,
the Duke of Saxony should be the next king.
Heinrich was an enemy of Conrad.
Conrad knew he was the man that could hold the nation together.
Conrad died in 1918 and the nobles appeared to agree with him electing Heinrich
as their next king.
A few months later,
Heinrich known as Heinrich there Fogler or Henry the Fowler after his hobby of
Falconry was the first native German to be King of Germany beginning the Saxon,
Tennessee.
The threat of the Magyars was an immediate concern of Heinrich upon his rise to
power,
though initially facing the fit against them,
he eventually had a stroke of luck to feeding the Magyars in taking a son of
their leader prisoner.
In exchange for the Magyar Prince's released.
He demanded 10 years of peace.
The brief cease fire allowed Heinrich the opportunity to continue war with the
Slavs train is infantry and build fortifications around his domain.
In nine 32 when the Magyars returned,
he defeated them at the battle of Riata dealing a major blow to them.
Heinrich was a great ruler militarily,
but he never consolidated power politically in a form of absolute rural either.
Germany persisted as he kind of confederation of semi autonomous Dutchies over
which she had limited power.
Nevertheless,
he had strengthened and protect the nation as a whole.
He died nine 36 and his son was elected that year.
Importantly,
Heinrich did divide his the main among his sons despite an opportunity to do so
living in all intact to a successor.
His son Otto would reign for nearly 40 years.
In that time,
his achievements and building the germination and the holy Roman Empire would
earn him the title.
It's a great
auto,
was ambitious and bold,
essentially viewing himself as no less than the successor of Charlemagne.
His reign was marked naturally early on by conflict with his younger brother and
the other German nobles and furthermore,
he was involved in the regular wars with Slavs,
vikings and French.
However,
as time went on,
auto actually began to break out of this continuous cycle of that caused this
disorder.
He defeated his arrivals and then again to try to transform the structure of the
germination of the time.
By centering power on the monarchy,
he would replace rebellious dukes and nobles with those loyal to him calm and
they relatives and intentionally overruled the authorities of all the others
signifying that loyalty to and cooperation with the monarch was the way forward.
He ruled from horseback,
often touring his domain for half the year.
He would endeavor to control the church and use it as a means to strengthen his
rule.
By the nine fifties he had settled many of his domestic troubles and began to
expand outward.
One of his prime interest was Italy where the widowed queen of Northern Italy,
Adelaide call to auto for help after bearing guard the second had you served her
husband's thrown auto cross the Alps and nine 51 where he took the city of
Fovea,
he would in turn Mary Adelaide,
his second wife,
this second marriage angered auto son from his first wife Leah dolls,
especially when she bore him.
A son who threatened lead dog succession outraged.
He would rebel against his father and nine 53 alongside other frustrated nobos.
The rebellions spiraled out of control and the situation was exacerbated when
the Magyars moved into Bavaria,
lead all would later become cooperative with the Magyars.
It was not long before the situation began to threaten autos,
rain itself,
but it would be abruptly ended and nine 54 partially because so many nobles felt
that in alliance with the Magyars was excessive.
Treachery Auto at times a very merciful ruler for gave his son for all his
crimes with the domestic situation.
Finally stable auto now turned his attention to the invading Magyars in the
spring of nine 55 war with the Magyars would resume but auto with the feed them
on multiple occasions throughout the year.
On August 10th the two sides,
we're squaring up for a major battle.
The Battle of Lek Feld near Augsburg and Bavaria Auto,
how to forests.
I'm around 8,000 men obtained from across Germany and Bohemia.
The Magyars live.
We had a forest around twice the size of this.
Despite this auto
had some favorable factors.
The battle was to take place on an aeroplane between two rivers,
the Magyars.
We're not as accustomed to fighting pitched battles.
They were horse archers who preferred hit and run tactics.
Despite this swarm of arrows that rained down on the German troops.
They were no match for autos.
Heavy cavalry,
the predecessor of the Medieval Knight,
they destroyed the Magyars in his battle dealing if fatal blow to them.
Following this,
the Magyars gave up on the rating of western Europe altogether that same year
auto would lead US forces to victory against the invading Slavs and pushed
further into their territory is victories over the foreign pagan invaders led to
many viewing him as the savior of Christendom.
Things were beginning to go smoothly for him when and nine 58 trouble in Italy
returned with Behringer auto intervened and by nine 62 he had taken much of
northern Italy for himself effectively conjoining,
northern Italy and Germany.
That year the pope would bestow upon him the same title which had been given to
Charlemagne emperor of Rome.
It's us as a result of this,
what would later be called the holy Roman Empire began or continued.
It is debated,
but regardless,
this was the beginning of a new age for the kings of Germany as the first Reich
with auto as the first German to hold the title is empire throughout the
centuries would be regarded not as an empire,
but as the empire,
not a state within Christendom,
but the true Christian state almost immediately,
however,
conflicts between the pope and emperor of again and auto had jaw,
the 12th deposed and replaced this would temporarily help things,
but outro would struggle with the papacy and Italy for the rest of his life and
would even have to end up ruling from Rome at certain points to stabilize
things.
Italy,
however,
would seldom in the empire's history be happy under the rule of the two tins and
would always be distant to try to ease relations with the Byzantines who were
again jealous of the title of Emperor of Rome,
which he had taken autos,
youngest and sole surviving son and heir,
also named auto at this time.
16 would marry a Byzantine Princess,
say,
oh Fano the emperor,
his niece who was at this time 12 auto would die the following year in
[inaudible] 73 out of the second to became king.
Immediately thereafter,
his position security even before his father's death as a noble is elected him
king with auto,
the first breathing down their necks.
Much of his reign was marked by domestic conflict,
which arose without his father there as well as a war with the Danes,
French Arabs,
Slavs and Byzantines.
But when he died suddenly at the age of 28 from malaria,
his young son who would be out of the third was elected and crowned.
Despite the issues facing the empire and an attempted usurpation,
the crown would successfully passed to auto the third when he was of age and
nine 94 out of the third though young was exceptionally bright and he envisioned
himself as the true ruler of Christendom,
the one who would truly revive the Roman Empire in January of 10 oh two however,
at the age of 21 he died while suppressing rebellion in Italy have a strange
sudden fever out of the third had died unexpectedly without having been married
and with no children.
Whatever future he envisioned,
along with the stability that the atony Ian's and our subjects had brought to
the empire would not be challenged as multiple contenders bickered for the
throne.
Eventually,
his cousin,
Heinrich Duka Bavaria would become king in a complicated and heated contention
in which rivals once more went to war,
but he became Heinrich this second and 10 oh two king of Italy and 10 oh four
and holy Roman emperor and 10 14 clearly much of his reign was spent trying to
secure the authority that the [inaudible] had wielded.
He also spend time fighting Poland over the territory of Bohemia,
the Modern Day Czech Republic,
the independent minded German nobles or printers weren't heartbroken to see a
distracted wheat king on a throne.
Heinrich died in 10 24 again with no air.
This brought an end to the Atonia and dentisty and once more the German nobles
would have to choose a king,
they would choose Conrad of the second,
thus beginning the salient dentisty Conrad like his predecessor is spent much of
his early rain traveling around his domain.
It may seem odd that a ruler would spend so little time and the capital city,
but at this time and for much of the time there was no capital city of the holy
Roman Empire.
The closest thing would have been the city of [inaudible],
but effectively the capital of the empire was wherever the emperor was in 10 30
to Conrad Incorporated Burgundy into his domain.
Though gained diplomatically at the top,
the nations still had to be taken by force burgundy along with the kingdoms of
Germany and Italy would form the base of the holy Roman Empire along with
Bohemia.
Although that is a different story.
The Holy Roman emperors though losing power slowly,
we're still at the time,
perhaps the strongest men in Europe,
but their power would soon be challenged again as the seeds of an inevitable
conflict planted as far back as Charlemagne began to sprout a power struggle
between the emperor and pope remembered as the investiture controversy.
As you recall,
the practice of using the church to keep a grasp over Germany and the whole
empire dates back quite far in a country struggling with unity.
The church was a centralizing unified force.
Bishops typically held similar power as a German princess up to this point.
Positions of power within the Church of Germany weren't handed out by the pope.
They were handed out by the emperors to ensure the church loyalty to him.
At times the emperor even felt he had the power to install or depose popes and
turn.
Though the pope was the sole person who could crown a king,
holy Roman emperor.
The notion that a German king or any second of Lord should have this power was
challenged by the Gregorian reform movement.
This refers to a focus on reforms such as allowing the pope to be elected by a
college of cardinals rather than appointed by the emperor and for the church to
be responsible in handling the positions of its own officials.
The reformers began in 10 56 not coincidentally at the same time of riot and
conspiracy in Germany under the six year old King Heinrich,
the fourth the situation escalated and 10 75 when Pope Gregory the seventh
issued the Dick Tatas pop by asserting that the church was founded by God,
that the pope alone can depose or in state bishops and that he may even depose
emperors.
Heinrich to fourth was not interested in complying with a list of rules that
would undermine his power.
He sent the pope a letter making his intentions quite clear that he intended to
remove him.
Pope Gregory though was prepared.
He soon announced that Heinrich the fourth was no longer king and excommunicated
him from the church.
Heinrich prepare to move south to depose the pope,
but he was prevented from doing so by native unrest is discontented.
Subjects leapt at the opportunity to legally rebel against him and he was
grounded by civil war with his subjects who had the support of the pope fearing
the feet.
And 10 77 at the city of Canosa in the famous walk to Canosa,
Heinrich marshed,
barefoot in Fenton clothing through the snow to see the pope where he waited in
fasted for three days at the castle gates until Pope Gregory finally received
him.
This act was humiliating to say the least Heinrich's predecessors could make or
break a pope with a wave their hands.
Now you're,
he was begging to one for his kingdom.
Nevertheless,
Heinrich was forgiven and his excommunication was lifted.
His relationship with the pope had been improved,
but the German nobles weren't so forgiving.
Rather,
they had designs to continue the great sex and revolt as it is called and elect
a new King Rudolph on Ryan Feldman.
The revolt would continue and in 10 80 things seem to get worse.
When Pope Gregory took the side of Rudolf and ex communicated Heinrich again
this time,
however,
Heinrich with prepared and he received a stroke of luck,
Rudolph would die that year.
The following year with the rebellion waning invaded Rome as Heinrich Marsh.
Further,
the pope was forced to call on a new ally recruiting the Normans,
who had recently occupied southern Italy and 10 84 they came to his rescue both
when the populous of Rome revolted against Norman occupation.
Norman's plundered and burned much of the city pole.
Gregory had one.
There's a port,
but now Rome opposed them and he had to leave with the Normans to return south
where he died.
A year later,
Heinrich VUSs elevated his choice for Pope Clement the third who crowned him
holy Roman emperor.
This would not end the conflict,
however,
and in fact the conflict but not end until 1122 when Heinrich son Heinrich's at
FIS who had often imposes father in fact signs the Concorde it a Vermes with
Pope Callixtus.
The second the church had effectively one,
it's right to greater power and independence.
This conflict Delta great blow cause the holy Roman Empire.
It saw the power of the papacy grow and the power of the empire began to weaken
as the nobility had resisted.
The power of the MODOC for so long in Germany that contradicting him was
commonplace.
Big Concept of separatism was greatly favored in northern Italy and to the West.
Amid this chaos and insubordination,
the English and French were beginning to supplant the empire.
His position as the leading power in Europe though the church had gained an
upper hand and though the title of Holy Roman emperor was still not an inherited
title,
rather one,
granted it's solely by the pope,
it would not be the end over the debate of who is ultimately more powerful
emperor or pope get into this period of history.
I suppose I should preface the holy Roman Empire to try to make it clearer to
understand a lot of people find the history and structure of the holy Roman
Empire to be bizarre and confusing and if it seems that way,
it's essentially because it is.
Even foreigners around it at the same time remarked that it was excessively
complicated and confusing.
We of course saw the auto [inaudible] is trying to consolidate power around the
monarchy and the salients held a good degree of power until the investiture
controversy as well.
But this problem of a lack of centralized authority does not get much better
over time and truth except for a few intervals.
It gets worse.
The emperor is don't really wield true unchallenged authority over everyone.
They are in regular conflict with the nobility and other forces of power in the
country like a church and cities,
and this feature kind of prevents it from unifying into a cohesive nation state.
In France and England for example,
we can see clear centralization of power,
a clear chain of command,
cohesion among the organs of the nation.
It's not always perfect,
but it works.
That doesn't happen with the holy Roman Empire.
It exists as a kind of loose union of microstates with too much autonomy to
really get the nation off its feet and moving as a real empire.
The micro states later have their own armies,
currencies,
laws,
that sort of thing.
And this is interesting because throughout the upcoming period of history,
Germany should have been a major power to rival France,
England,
Spain later on.
However,
a number of bizarre circumstances prevented the power within the country from
being harnessed,
and that doesn't change until much later.
Not to say that this was some sort of failed state.
However,
it was unusual,
but it did last for a thousand years,
which suggests that there is a method to the madness which we shall see as the
Christian world came under threat by Islamic of the Holy Land.
Around the same time as the investiture controversy,
Germany finding itself greatly wounded by these events,
participated very little on the first crusade.
Rather,
it fell in a period of relative isolation.
In 1125 Heinrich,
the fifth died childless as the last ruler of the salient dentisty.
Accordingly,
Conrad of the whole hinged off and dentisty eventually came to the throne after
attempts to prevent him and an interregnum and 1152 Conrad's nephew Friedrich
was elected king.
One of Friedrich's first acts was to begin campaigning in Italy.
Subduing the independent minded northern Italians,
the Melanie's in particulare.
Eventually he reached Rome where he was crowned Holy Roman emperor.
While in Italy,
Friedrich would be given a name by which he is better known to this day red
beard or an Italian barber.
Rossa.
Shortly thereafter,
Barbara Rossa married Beatrice of Burgundy,
securing his rule over all three main components of the empire.
One's more on their wedding.
They engaged in a ritual which today may seem unusual to us.
Their marriage,
which was a greatly political event,
was consummated in front of many important figures and foreign representatives.
Thankfully,
the details of this event were meticulously recorded,
which I shall now narrate to you.
Barbarosa would spend much visceral struggling with Italy and the Pope Alexander
the third.
This struggle in fact was to lead to the placement of holy in the term holy
Roman Empire or Sacrum and Pentium Romano and Latin Heidi Degas remissions
writes in German,
the term holy was not meant to show fidelity to the pope.
Rather,
it was added to show in the pendants from him implying that the position of
emperor was not some reward from the church.
It was a position handed by God directly to the emperor.
Without the Pope's involvement.
Barbarosa would campaign in Italy five times.
He had goals to extend control all the way to Sicily,
but in the end he was defeated by the Lombard League and alliance of many
rebellious states of northern Italy as well as the Pope Venice,
Sicily,
and the Byzantines at the battle of [inaudible].
Barbarosa would also have to deal with power struggles at home as well.
His cousin Heinrich,
their liver,
Henry the Lion Duke of Bavaria and Saxony was an increasingly powerful
individual in his territory's.
He was keenly interested in founding cities and expanding his power.
One such city and Bavaria was a town called mention home of the monks today,
the city of Munich,
which remains as Bavaria's capital along with Bavaria and Saxony,
high north of lion,
also pressed East and the Slavic Lens,
a holy mission to convert the Slavs and Baltic peoples.
The last year a peon pagans to Christianity also presented an opportunity for
Germans of all social status to expand eastward into sparsely inhabited and
undeveloped lands.
This expansion,
which would last
for centuries,
is collectively referred to as Aussie Cielo.
The East is settling.
The all seed long would soon evolve into a lesser known chapter of the Crusades,
one which prominently featured Germans and Germany,
the northern Crusades,
as well as Danes,
Swedes and holes,
Heinrich.
The lines power would increase the point of him being able to challenge
Barbarossa,
even refusing to campaign with them in Italy.
Barbarossa viewing this as treachery,
stripped him of his titles and exiled him for some time to England.
This did not solve the lack of cohesion among his nation at home and abroad that
he was facing.
However,
Barbara Rose's last campaign would be the third crusade where he endeavored to
reclaim the holy land from the Muslim invaders in tandem with the French King
Phillip Augustus and the English King Richard the Lionheart before he could
reach the Holy Land.
However,
in 1190 Barbarosa fell off his horse into a river where he drowned to death.
He was succeeded by his son,
Heinrich,
who became Heinrich the sixth he would rule for seven years during which time he
expanded the empire all the way to Sicily territorial claim,
which concern the pope.
He died in 1197 his son Frederick was only three at a time and the throne became
disputed as to kings were elected.
Heinrich,
the sixth brother fill up the first and Heinrich,
the lions son out of the fourth civil war erupted and continued until Friedrich
a second came of age.
When he did,
he won the pope's support by promising to let go of Sicily and me came
undisputed king in 1215 he won the support of his nobles by doing what his
predecessors has struggled in vain against granted the nobility further rights,
and in the pendants,
Friedrich is remembered as a rather bright,
in fact,
intellectual king,
Friedrich Nietzsche.
I would later refer to him as the first European speaking of Sicily.
Despite his promise to the pope,
he did not release it.
He was actually able to form a strong effect of centralized government there.
This anger the pope.
Furthermore,
Friedrich was crown promising that he would embark on a crusade which she had
thus far failed to do as well.
In fact,
his hesitation to embark on the fifth crusade is often cited as the reason for
its failure.
Friedrich would be excommunicated four times throughout his life and his
struggles with the papacy even being called the antichrist.
On one occasion by Pope Gregory the Ninth Friedrich would embark on a crusade.
However,
two in fact,
the sixth crusade where he miraculously one Jerusalem by negotiation,
which the pope hoping for a great battle wasn't happy about.
And of course the northern Crusades,
Friedrich had elevated Herrmann von Salsa to beat the grandmaster of the
Teutonic order around 1210 the Teutonic knights would be key to expanding into
territory such as of the Bonia and crusher.
In fact,
they had been granted permission to rule over the pagan territories,
which they conquered.
The Teutonic orders rule over the territory of Prussia would lead to massive
German migration and the German ization of the people there,
which would have long term effects on German and European history.
Friedrich's Ryan became greatly unstable in the 1240s as the papacy fought
against him and engineered plots to overthrow him.
Notably with an archbishop support of two different rival kings,
they'll helm Poland and Henry Rusbay.
Meanwhile,
the Teutonic order was taking on the far reaches of the Mongol army and the
middle of the struggle and 1250 Friedrich died.
His son died only a few years later ending Ho hinged off in rural.
The Holy Roman empire was effectively entering into it's first grade interregnum
or no king was able to receive on the spewed at approval until 1272 though
confusion and uncertainty would last longer than us in both the empire and the
Pepsi.
The power of the nobility and bishops only fed off this increasing their power
in cementing their autonomy with each Nobel commonly building his own castle to
cement his authority.
In this time period,
Germany is today one of the most castled regions in the world,
despite a major lack of central authority.
However,
the German kingdom would continue and many of its endeavors,
including the push eastward,
which was less effected by Home Affairs.
Ahmed,
this confusion and the vision.
A Rosa House,
which would come to be one of the most important in the holy Roman Empire,
and one of the most influential houses and European history from the arch Duchy
of Austria,
which has split off from a varia in a 12th century came the Habsburgs.
The first Habsburg to be elected king was Rudolph the first though King of
Germany,
he would not be holy Roman emperor.
The ecclesiastical and sec of the is during this time,
we're not interested in a leader.
They were interested in a servant and we're more resilient than ever towards the
king's attempts to rule them accordingly.
This was not the Habsburgs rise to power.
It was only temporary foreshadowing as it would be some time before they had a
permanent hold on Germany.
The Habsburgs lost power in Germany.
After Rudolph though,
he had established his family by making his sons that dukes of Austria and
Steria,
the German electors fearing the power of the house,
thus elected kings from different houses,
some of whom were chosen specifically because they lacked power and would be
weak rulers from the surface.
This arrangement of things probably appears who have a greatly favor of the
princess.
However,
in turn,
the princess found themselves struggling to maintain rural over there domains
and the nobility church nights and cities within them who often acted
independently as well.
The cities in Germany in particular and his time period operated fairly
independently.
They weren't exactly cities states like in Italy,
but they weren't always subservient to the surrounding country and oftentimes
they banded together to promote their own interest.
One example of this is the Honda diotic league from the German word [inaudible],
which means guilt,
which was both a trading and also at offensively administered by German
merchants extending from London to Novgorod by the 15th century.
Some of these cities became imperial cities,
which were effectively as autonomous as other parts of the country.
Heinrich.
The seventh was crown king in 1308 becoming holy Roman emperor and 1312 during
his reign,
the Teutonic knights capture the city of Gdansk or in German,
Don's linking Germany and Prussia geographically.
Heinrich died a few years into his reign though and was succeeded by his son
Ludvig that forests in a contested election.
The pope furthermore refuse to acknowledge his claims,
but in 1338 the German electors agreed to the declaration of runs a.
In this declaration they stated that the right of the emperor to rural,
it was no longer dependent on the pope's approval.
Whomever the electors chose to be king would be king and with the title of King
automatically came the title of Holy Roman emperor or in German,
Kaiser from the Latin Chi's are,
or as we more commonly pronounced it Caesar.
This decision later paved the way for the golden bowl of 1356 to be issued under
Carl fourth who is also king of Bohemia and a part of the house of Luxembourg
beginning his reign as well as the reign of his house.
In 1346 the golden bowl finally solidified and organize the process by which
emperors would be elected.
The emperors would be elected by seven career footsteps or prince electors.
Three of them were ecclesiastical.
The Archbishop of minds,
the Archbishop of Cologne and the Archbishop of trior for were secular,
the king of Bohemia,
the counts Palatine of the Rhine,
the Duke of Saxony Vandenberg,
and the Margrave of Brandenburg.
The Golden Bowl is a times referred to as the German magna Carta.
These changes marked the beginning of a new identity for the holy Roman Empire.
It would end or attempt to end constant civil war has caused by succession
debates,
but in truth to a degree,
it was a significant milestone on the empire's gradual path toward irrelevancy.
The empire had lost its vision of being a universal Christian Empire.
The emperor's,
we're now dependent on the electors.
This would greatly impede his ability to project power beyond its own borders.
Around the same time that these changes were occurring,
Germany was invaded by a new enemy.
The black death caused by three different strains of plague between 1347 and
1351 it would kill around half of Europe's population.
Germany was,
thankfully not hit quite as hard,
but it was still dealt a heavy blow by losing 20% of its population.
When Carl the fourth died,
his son wants a slouch,
was elected in 1378 yet once this Laos was deposed by the electors in 1400 his
behavior was seen as rather degenerate and is rural and effective.
Though he did remain king of Bohemia,
he was replaced by a roof racks the third as long as once it stops lived.
However,
Rupe Rex rain was contested and domestic conflict was a feature throughout his
reign on the verge of civil war and 1410 we're prek died and the ones this Laos
wanted the throne it would pass to his younger brother.
Sigismund as men,
was a bright and energetic man and was in fact already king of Hungary.
He had spent considerable time campaigning against the Muslim Ottomans as the
head of the order of the Dragon Sigismund.
Early rain was marked by handling a large number of affairs.
He would go to war with the Venetians.
He would be very much involved in the two tonic Polish wars interrupting to the
northeast,
and he would help and the papal schism,
a dispute which had divided the church among three competing pope's.
He would do this with his suggestion of the Council of Constance at the council
of Constance as well.
The matter of a Catholic priest named Aeon whois was addressed.
Yon whois was a Bohemian or check reformer who had wanted to change the behavior
and practices in the Catholic Church and a time when it's schism was
deteriorating.
It's image whois wasn't tolerated and he was burned at the stake.
And 1415 and constants,
despite Sigismund is a vow of protection.
This would not end the discontent,
however,
rather it would enrage it as many checks and favorite hoose and viewed him.
Now as a martyr public unrest brewed in Bohemia,
which evolved into civil war in 1419 once a Laos died and Sigismund came to the
throne of Bohemia as well,
declaring that he would drown all the hussite heretics.
In 1421 the pope escalated the situation by calling a crusade against the host
site,
checks the hood sites weren't pushovers the conflict that was emerging with last
for years,
and they in fact took the flight to Germany,
Hungary,
and the two tonic lands where they aligned themselves with the Polish and the
Polish Teutonic war of 1431 35 the host sites themselves,
however soon split into separate branches and the requests,
the more moderate of the two were victorious.
The war ended in 1434 with a mix of results.
Neither side was really victorious.
The host sites were reincorporated into Bohemia,
but they were allowed to continue practicing some of their religious Gleaves.
Sigismund died the following year.
His successor would be Friedrich to third from the House of Habsburg,
another house he Hohenzollern had gained power in Brandenburg,
Prussia with the compromise between the Hussites and Catholics.
More radical church reform would be delayed by a century,
but it was coming.
Reform which would rock Christianity in Europe to its core will be sparked under
a German monk named Martin Luther.
In the next video,
we will see where all this leads and learn how Germany copes with the rise of
Protestantism and later the beginnings of modern Europe.
We will explore the roles of the Austrian impression empires,
Napoleon's empire,
the unification of Germany,
the world wars,
and the modern nation of today.
I hope you've enjoyed this video.
If you'd like to stay up to date with part two as well as to see other videos
I've made such as these documentaries here on history and science and other
upcoming videos.
I encourage you to check out fire of learning and subscribe to help support the
costs of production.
Fire of learning does take donations on patrion linked to which you can find in
the description.
The patrion was down for a little bit,
but it is now back up and I would like to take a moment to thank Chris Yates,
Jonathan Trillo and to Marek Steffenson for their support.
Also,
by the way,
we are now on Instagram,
so hey,
follow us there.
Donka for watching.